purée
je
le toit d'une voiture c'est loin d'être
une scène traditionnelle mais c'est
devenu la voie de l'avenir pour
mcmasters
[Musique]
en
en raison de la coved 19 la longue
carrière de la star country de cagliari
s'est arrêté du jour au lendemain en
mars j'étais très peur parce que tous
les choses que je travaille pour ma vie
adulte et s'est terminé comme ça moi
j'ai trois petites enfants et ma famille
dépendent sur la sur ma musique c'est en
voyant un photographe de cagliari
prendre des portraits des gens sur leur
perron qu'il a eu l'idée des clubs s'ils
consultent les concerts sur le trottoir
il y avait une moitié de moi qui pensais
l'idée était trop impossible mais j'ai
commencé la première journée j'avais un
concert la deuxième journée une autre
concert dessiné ce n'est pas arrêté
l'idée a fait boule de neige au point
que mcmasters a pu recruter des artistes
dans six régions du pays comme amber
rose winnipeg et satee on ne joue pas
gratuitement ratel amber rose
non
grâce à ce nouveau modèle d'affaires les
artistes peuvent bien gagner leur vie et
mcmasters pourrait même leur offrir des
assurances médicales et dentaires
du jamais vu dans cette industrie les
adeptes de ce nouveau modèle d'affaires
croit d'ailleurs qu'il est là pour
rester la connexion est très très
spécial c'est très personnel c'est
beaucoup plus personnel que n'importe
quoi ce que j'ai fait avant en amenant
la musique directement sur le perron du
canadien mc marcheuse a su faire d'une
défaite
une véritable histoire à succès il
faudrait 9 e radio canada séguin
[Applaudissements]